Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Todos los días yo tengo dos,
tres y hasta cinco reuniones
con las personas de
los ámbitos más diversos:
jueces, narcotraficantes,
políticos, empresarios
y la chismosa de tu barrio.
Sí, la chismosa de tu barrio
habla conmigo.
Ese es mi trabajo,
porque yo busco información.
Pero una información muy específica.
Sobre los delincuentes de cuello blanco.
Los expertos en la corrupción, el lavado,
el narcotráfico, el fraude corporativo.
Los llamados delincuentes
de cuello blanco que se visten así.
No se visten como en la serie de TV.
Todos los días, por esto,
me tengo que reunir además,
y hablo con mis editores,
porque tenemos que cruzar información
y tratar de separar lo que
son datos de versiones.
Y esto es bastante más difícil
de lo que parece.
Porque ¡les garantizo que la realidad
en este país supera la ficción!
Solo en esta vida paralela es que,
por ejemplo, es posible que
uno de los más grandes
operadores judiciales
de los últimos 25 años
reciba a sus invitados,
sea para hablar de un gobierno o de otro,
en el quincho de su casa
rodeado de dos posters,
una caja de vidrio
y un "persuasor".
Póster número uno:
Al Pacino en Caracortada.
Póster número dos:
Marlon Brando en El Padrino.
Caja de vidrio con
un teléfono celular dorado
--¿recuerdan los viejitos, los sapitos?--
que cuando le preguntás te dice:
"Ese era el teléfono celular que
yo solo usaba con el número uno".
El día que el número uno murió,
decidí que este teléfono
no se podía volver a tocar.
Y el "persuasor" es un bate
de aluminio de 1,20 m
que él mismo aclara que es para que,
si alguno de sus invitados
se desubica, ponerlo en orden.
Este señor es apenas
uno de los que se mueven
por los sótanos de la Argentina.
En estos sótanos es donde yo trabajo.
En estos sótanos, de hecho,
--aclaro que este hombre no es
ni siquiera de los más bravos, ¿eh?--
pero en esos sótanos se definen
algunos de los asuntos
más graves y sensibles
de la vida institucional de la Argentina
de los últimos 25 a 30 años.
Y es allí en lugares como este
donde se guardan
algunos de los secretos
más incómodos del poder.
Les voy a contar uno:
En la Argentina si vos, vos, vos, vos...
cualquiera quiere competir
por la presidencia,
va a necesitar USD 100 millones.
Repito la cifra. Sí, son USD 100 millones.
Uno dice, es muchísimo.
Si querés competir para
intendente de Escobar, o de La Plata,
necesitás entre USD 500 000
y USD 1 millón.
En algunas ciudades el comprar
tu puesto para el tercer lugar
en la lista de concejales de una
ciudad mediana cuesta USD 100 000.
Les aclaro algo: esto lo saben todos.
No es algo muy difícil de conseguir.
Lo saben los políticos,
lo saben los empresarios,
lo saben los narcos, lo saben todos.
De hecho, como lo saben también
los organismos de control
que deberían controlar.
Por eso el año que viene
nosotros vamos a encarar
una campaña presidencial
salvo que, o la economía, o alguna
reforma legislativa de último momento,
o que las investigaciones judiciales
que ahora tenemos en marcha
modifiquen esto,
todo aquel que quiera competir por
la presidencia o llegar a la Casa Rosada
necesita USD 100 millones.
Por eso es que solemos definir
al financiamiento electoral
como el pecado original de la política.
Arrancaste pecando.
Vos podés tener muy buenas
intenciones, grandes ideas,
pero a los pies los vas a tener
que llenar de barro.
¿Qué significa esto en la práctica?
Que por arriba de la superficie
podés tener candidatos
que compiten entre sí, debaten,
y por debajo de la superficie
podés tener que un candidato
financie la campaña de otro
porque le muerde votos
a su principal contendiente.
Y este, que no es estúpido,
a su vez financia la campaña de otro
para morderle votos a su principal rival.
Del mismo modo que
otra verdad incómoda del poder
es que como se necesitan fortunas,
y fortunas que a su vez si cumplís
con la legislación vigente,
no podés recaudar esos USD 100 millones,
tenés que pedir que la inmensa
mayoría del dinero
--se calcula que el 90 %--
sea en negro.
Esto lleva a que necesitás
cash y valijeros.
Del otro lado, ¿quiénes son
los que ponen el dinero?
Primero: empresarios.
Alguno de los grandes empresarios
que ahora estamos viendo desfilar
por Tribunales.
Y muchos de ellos, aclaro,
como no pueden sacar fondos
de sus balances,
ofrecen pago en especie.
¿Qué significa esto?
Venís y pedís USD 500 000.
No te puedo dar,
tengo una fábrica de empanadas.
Te ofrezco, te doy las empanadas
para todos los actos de campaña
en todos los lugares
donde tengo una sucursal.
El que tiene o fabrica autos,
entrega autos.
El que fabrica o distribuye celulares,
te entrega celulares para tu campaña.
Esta es una realidad de los sótanos.
Uds. pueden decir:
Bueno, ¿en qué se gastan estos,
por ejemplo, USD 100 millones?
Por otro lado, ¿estos son los únicos? No.
Porque tenés empresarios
que apuestan por los candidatos
como si fueran caballos de carrera.
Apuesto por el primero,
pero al mismo tiempo, por el segundo.
Y, por las dudas que salte la banca,
también por el tercero.
Y no solamente los empresarios.
La policía, por ejemplo, muchas veces
prepara bolsos de la recaudación ilegal
y los entrega.
¿Para qué? Para generar
un compromiso de ida y vuelta.
Ahora yo sé que vos sabés. Y es mutuo.
Y los narcos, cada elección,
están llegando más lejos y más alto.
Y por el lado de los gastos,
dos son los grandes rubros
cuando hablamos con los equipos
de campaña fuera de micrófono
y hablamos en serio.
El primero: la impresión de boletas
electorales y los fiscales.
El segundo: los periodistas
y los medios de comunicación.
Rubro uno: en el mundo se calcula
que necesitás 1,3 boletas
electorales por persona.
En la Argentina...
cinco, porque te las roban.
(Risas)
Con una combinación adicional,
si te roban la boleta tenés que
preparar a todos los fiscales.
Decís: No puede ser tanto dinero,
si son voluntarios.
Sí, pero los tenés que capacitar.
Los tenés que llevar
al centro de votación.
Tienen que tener un jefe superior
con un teléfono celular.
Les tenés que dar una vianda,
y traer de vuelta.
Multipliquen esto por 95 000
mesas electorales que tuvimos en 2015,
van a ser más ahora en 2019.
Y por el otro lado: medios
de comunicación y periodistas.
Este es uno de los rubros más caros.
No les sorprende lo difícil que es a veces
hablar con un candidato,
que no consigue nadie
y, finalmente, cuando ese candidato
acepta hablar
en una entrevista periodística
la pregunta más difícil que le hacen es:
"¿Hace calor en Jujuy?"
(Risas)
La entrevista más cara de 2015
costó USD 42 000.
Dicho por ellos,
por los equipos de campaña.
Ahora, me centré
en el financiamiento electoral,
y estos son los usos y costumbres
de los sótanos de este sector.
Y a su vez esto está dentro de
un entramado que incluye mucho más.
Porque también incluye, por ejemplo,
a los policías que mencioné antes,
con un dato adicional.
Hay muchas comisarías que se licitan,
se subastan, se rematan.
Se la queda el comisario
que ofrezca más dinero.
Entonces, yo ofrezco por tal comisaría
pagar USD 100 000 por mes.
Entonces, si aceptan mi oferta,
después tengo que recaudar dinero
a como dé lugar.
¿De dónde? ¿Cómo?
Estos son los policías
y aclaro que en cada uno de los rubros
hay muchísimas y muy honrosas salvedades.
Y no hay que generalizar.
Estoy contando cómo es un entramado.
Del mismo modo, hay muchos
periodistas que no informan.
Cobran por su silencio.
Hay fiscales que no investigan,
cajonean expedientes.
Hay jueces que se encargan
de prescribir los expedientes.
Empresarios que no compiten,
se cartelizan.
Sindicalistas, algunos que defienden
a los trabajadores
y muchos otros que entienden clarísimo
la premisa básica de que
no hay mejor huelga que la que no se hace
pero te permite negociar.
Por eso, si tenemos
un entramado de este tipo,
que es donde nosotros
--este es nuestro trabajo--
--y hablo de mí
y de muchos otros colegas--
si este es el entramado que tenemos,
es un error quedarse solamente
en los personajes propios
de película de clase B.
Hombres que revolean bolsos
de dinero en conventos
o que andan manejando Ferraris.
Porque esos hombres son
en realidad muchas veces
solo la punta de un iceberg
que es mucho más profundo
y que incluye a lo que denominamos
"el poder permanente".
Y les voy a dar una anécdota
sobre esto.
Una vez hablando con un veterano
exsecretario de finanzas,
me contaba que en su primera semana
en el Ministerio de Economía
no sabía ni manejar
la botonera del teléfono.
Entonces recibe a los banqueros,
se tuvo que levantar,
le pidió a la secretaria
que por favor convoque al mozo.
Viene el mozo y le dice:
"¿Qué se va a servir?"
Le dice: "Un té con limón".
Se dio vuelta, miró a los banqueros,
y les dice: "¿Lo de siempre, no?"
Quien está de paso.
Y quien es permanente.
¿Esto es algo propio solo
de la Argentina? No.
De hecho, allí tenemos
los casos de Perú, de Italia,
de Brasil en las últimas décadas.
Que además nos muestran que tuvieron
problemas de corrupción [sistémica]
o megacorrupción o corrupción estructural,
como se las suele denominar,
y también tuvieron problemas posteriores.
¿Cuáles? Por ejemplo, en Italia
tenían la Tangentópolis
que se investigó con Mani pulite
y terminaron con un premiere italiano
correteando a menores de edad
por una finca romana.
O terminamos ahora en Brasil
después del Lava Jato
con un presidente electo
de extrema derecha,
defensor de la dictadura,
xenófobo y racista.
Y este es uno de los riesgos
que tenemos en la Argentina.
Salir de un problema
para terminar en un problemón.
Esto es un riesgo.
El otro es caer en el gatopardismo.
¿Qué significa esto?
Simular cambios que no ocurren.
Y esto es una dicotomía entre
lo que es la Argentina real
y la Argentina teórica.
En la Argentina teórica,
tenemos una Oficina Anticorrupción.
En la Argentina real, la Oficina
Anticorrupción tiene dos sedes.
Una de las dos sedes no tenía Internet.
Se colgaba del wifi del bar de la esquina.
El día del gastronómico
cerraba el bar y no tenían wifi,
no había Internet.
Todos Uds. con los teléfonos celulares
tienen más capacidad de búsqueda
que toda esa área de la Oficina
Anticorrupción. Ejemplo uno.
Ejemplo dos, la justicia electoral.
Los encargados de controlar
todos los verdaderos gastos e ingresos
de todo candidato electoral,
tiene el llamado
Cuerpo Nacional de Auditores.
Son los encargados de controlar
todos los ingresos, todos los gastos,
de todos los candidatos,
de todos los partidos,
en todos los ciclos electorales,
cada dos años.
¿Saben cuántos son?
--Y aclaro, son muy buenos--
Público: Nueve.
Son siete.
(Risas)
Tuvieron que, por expediente
administrativo, pedir una fotocopiadora.
(Risas)
Les voy a contar una intimidad.
Una sola vez papá me vino a ver
a una charla.
Terminó y me dijo:
"M’hijito, lo tuyo es brillante,
pero depresivo".
(Risas)
"Tratá de subirlo un poco,
porque es para agarrarse
los dedos con una puerta".
Además, la expresión de mi papá es esta.
(Risas)
Por lo tanto, respetando la promesa
que le hice a mi padre, les cuento:
¿Es posible corregir esto? Sí.
¿Es difícil? Mucho.
Y en realidad abrevo de lo que
ya han aprendido otros,
como el gran investigador
de la investigación italiana,
Mani pulite, Antonio Di Pietro.
Para que vean el coraje que tuvo,
se tuvo que ir a vivir a otro país.
Marco Canale era su nombre falso
mientras lo buscaban para matarlo.
Él y otros como él cuentan
que el momento clave,
el punto de inflexión, es cuando
los ciudadanos se involucran
y empiezan a ejercer presión;
meten presión.
Él cuenta: Solo pudo cambiar cuando
los italianos dijeron "basta".
Y esto es posible.
Si nosotros lo hacemos, y metemos presión,
podemos lograr la reforma electoral
que imponga la boleta única,
y terminamos con el robo de boletas.
O sacar a la Oficina Anticorrupción
de la órbita del Poder Ejecutivo.
Y muchos otros ejemplos. Muchísimos.
De hecho, lo hemos tenido en Argentina.
Infinidad de veces.
La marcha del silencio en Catamarca
para exigir que se resolviera el homicidio
de la chiquita Morales.
O el dos por uno,
cuando hubo un fallo de la Corte
y se movilizó la ciudadanía.
O la 125. Elijan Uds.
El debate por la legalización del aborto.
Los legisladores no iban a los debates.
Y de repente vieron que la ciudadanía
sí estaba involucrada
en algo que ellos no.
Y a favor o en contra, pero tuvieron
que ponerse los pantalones.
Entonces, sí es posible
pero depende de nosotros.
(Aplausos)
Porque va a depender de nosotros
y va a depender de meter mucha presión
es que es clave el esfuerzo cotidiano.
Y hasta que eso no ocurra,
yo y otros como yo,
nos moveremos por el sótano
hablando con los Tony Montana
y los Vito Corleone
y esquivando los bates de aluminio.
(Aplausos)